niché aux confins de l'indre un des
nombreux moulins à eau du département
dont l'activité est sérieusement menacée
il y a 20 ans christian d'alu a racheté
et restauré la bâtisse pluriséculaire
dans l'objectif de produire de
l'hydroélectricité
mais avec ce nouveau décret qui veut
supprimer toute forme de retenue d'eau
pour faciliter la circulation des
poissons migrateurs difficile pour ce
fils de meunier d'y croire encore les
moulins qu'ils tiennent à coeur un peu
tout le monde en fait parce qu'on sait
tous élevés au pied d'un moulin la
rivière lot me bats pour essayer de le
faire et vous voyez la roue qui tourne
mon c'est quand même agréable et on est
ici je connais un peu la faune ici il y
avait beaucoup de poissons avant lé
seuil était pas ça n'empêchait pas les
poissons de remonter quoi ni des voix à
quelques kilomètres de là le maire d'une
petite commune a racheté ce moulin pour
le réhabiliter en gîte
ce moulin lorsqu'il sera équipé pourra
produire de l'électricité
jean-louis chesaux se bat pour
sauvegarder ce patrimoine qui en mille
ans d'existence selon lui a fait ses
preuves et ne demande qu'à reprendre du
service
ce n'est pas le manque de poisson nous
risquons c'est le manque d'eau il faut
donc refaire des réserves et les rendre
vivantes et en même temps faire de
l'hydroélectricité parce que la creuse à
des débits autant de les spots et si on
revient et un minot on aura plus d'eau
on aura plus de poisson c'est simple
c'est tellement simple que
que je comprends pas voilà un décret
pour assurer la continuité écologique
dans les faits une décision pour ces
propriétaires qui pourrait bien
défigurer le paysage du berry